foreign
[Laughter]
for y'all so we want to get into
uh
I completely forgot come on it's not you
were making so much more story though
bruh it kind of is literally Brad no no
it's good it's advice for reference bro
okay yes so advice for reverse we want
to get into advice for reverts and
advice for Muslims who may not be
purchased in the world but you know
they're aware of this they want to
change this because let's be honest you
have non-muslims who you know a lot of
guys to Islam but you have borne Muslims
who Allah brings back to the video Dean
the dean of Islam so
start with you bro
what an amazing uh intro that we just
had right now
it's good it's good uh you know
subhanallah you mentioned a good point
Brad bro bringing people back to Islam
and
um sometimes that's just what needs to
happen and remember that the scars that
we have tell a really unique story a lot
of us run away from that idea of scars
we try to like you know mask up and have
these perfect perceptions of who we are
and you know a person may be watching
the first time sees you or sees someone
like myself who just has tattoos at all
Muslim tattoo how does that make sense
you know each scar tells a story it
tells who we used to be and it's a sign
that we've grown it's a sign that we've
grown and uh for those of you feeling
like alienated a little bit but I'm not
a real how am I going to benefit from
this no there's going to be a lot for
everyone to benefit from this inshallah
so you know for me you know going we
were speaking about this as well too
what brought me back to Islam was a
breakup
it was a breakup it was me getting my
heart broken bro it was I I feel like
I've always been a hopeless romantic I
don't know if anyone could like buy with
that being a hopeless romantic I
explained
I just feel like I would do anything for
love
it's time you're one of those it's
better to love and lose than to never
love at all yeah I I I would just I
would like I would be that person who
would write you a letter and just do
something different you know like maybe
get you a rose oh okay okay
yeah I would I would just write you a
letter and just do something completely
different maybe get you a flower and you
know what you might not even
reciprocated to me back you know you
that might not lead me to get a date
that might not lead me to have anything
happen with you but at least I did it
you know I don't have to live with that
regret of you know what if I would have
like tried to ask him out or whatever
the case might be and I've had this bro
where there was this really you know
cute girl at the time
[Laughter]
yeah yeah there was this girl
um in my math class so I studied
mathematics in University for my
undergrad right believe it or not
and uh
she was just like you know I liked her
you know she was she was in all my
classes and I'd like to whatever the
case maybe one day I was just like you
know what just do it get a little Rose
and doing all that sort of stuff I gave
the road oh thank you so much and I just
felt like a lane nothing happened but at
least I did it you know at least I could
say that hey I did do it I didn't need
to go about it and I just feel like
maybe because I didn't get the love at
home I needed I thought that I needed to
get love from other people and that for
me that was a big Point bro because and
we spoke a little bit off camera about
abusive households and growing up in
abusive household and you know our
structure of love and our definition of
love
comes from what we see you know and me
seeing how my father showed his love
towards my mom towards my sister towards
myself that's the definition of what I
know love is so I never received it I
craved it I thought that that I would be
complete when I get it from someone when
you know the love is within you you know
Allah
you know he is the all-loving he's the
loving if we want love we need to go to
the source of love not the creation
that's a big mistake that a lot of us
make right we think that we're going to
be complete when we get in that
relationship so we don't care because we
want the love so anyone out there really
struggling my my immediate goal would be
like hey like why are you why are you
chasing love so much right what's not
right in your life right now that's
causing you to want love from other
people because people would even get
married even in a Halal way but they put
all their eggs in that basket for that
person relying fully on that person
thinking that by marrying them they will
complete them but Venus you know you're
you're you're when you get married half
of your Dean is completed but notice
that you have to come with your own
completed Deen to receive the other half
of your deed that means the Five Pillars
and the basics of your Dean that has to
be on point by you and when you have
that you will still find out the
incomplete until you have your spouse
right look at Adam bro he was in Jannah
think about it bro Jannah like Jannah
has everything it's Jannah we all want
Jannah but he was incomplete still and
Allah knew what he needed he didn't know
what he needed Allah knew what he needed
he needed a companion and he gave him a
companion from him right from him so we
know that a lot of us feel incomplete we
want love we we want a companion we like
it you know but you gotta also remember
that there's people out there who are
slimy bro slimy and they will take
advantage of the fact that you're pure
you're pure hearted you know that you
you mean good you're a genuine person
and they will have hidden agendas and
take advantage of you right now does
that mean that you don't trust in your
love and you give up on love no it means
you put your trust in Allah you do it
you make a lot of you you you you tie
your camel like we said in the last
podcast that we did months ago
um and we we we put our full trust in
Allah you know we put our full trust in
Allah we know that Allah you're gonna
handle this for me so uh I think that
for me bro being a hopeless magic
definitely came from
not getting that love at home for sure
bro
it's crazy man it's crazy that you say
that because uh and this is
I I almost oh no we're going into this
like we're yeah
Am I Dreaming right now you know when
you're dreaming you're like how did I
end up here yeah no but uh before I was
a Muslim
um I definitely did that I looked for
that love externally because I didn't
really receive it
um in the household and
um
damn like it wasn't until recently that
I feel like I started to just kind of
give give myself that love you know
because I knew like a lot a lot provides
everything so I knew like look like
Allah is going to give me this external
love but first I need to have internal
love for my own self yes sir you know
and like I'm not gonna say everything
but
I can see that hmm well I can see that
we want to know from y'all if if y'all
have similar stories or want to share
about you know because we all have
different childhoods you know how that
shaped you as an adult how that shaped
your entire life you know if that did
affect you and how you express love how
you like to receive love your definition
of Love or even if you you're just not a
hopeless romantic you're the opposite of
that if you don't love
stuff bro for a lot of people but I do
want to tie back into the trajectory
we're going to that's what I was about
to say I just remember yeah
so okay so you said this is what brought
you back to Islam yeah
in what way yeah cause a breakup bro
doesn't that like usually turn people
the other way yeah yeah so for me
personally
um and and I think for anyone who's been
in love or what they thought love was
you know rami's a lover boy
oh boy okay
[Laughter]
um you know
you don't realize how incomplete you are
until you find that person they really
love and care about that they make you
whole and you never realize this whole
time you were never complete and when
they come into your life it feels so
good it feels great you know the thought
of them leaving or the thought of that
love no longer being existent is a scary
thought it brings anxiety into a lot of
people uh it's part of the reason a lot
of people say in abusive relationships
is part of the reason people never get
out when they should have got out they
see those red flags but because they
just want to be loved you know and again
this is advice why is this in tying into
reverts and all that it's all going to
make sense in Charlotte It's gotta gotta
keep just pay attention it all right to
stay with us inshallah it all come
together inshallah so like you know like
when when me and this person broke up
right
I felt that knife that emptiness that
hollowness that before always was there
but I never knew its existence because I
never knew what it felt like to feel
quote-unquote whole you're trying to
cover it up yeah I felt like what they
did by that breakup is it exposed how
broken I've always been I've always been
a broken man you know and I I and and
you know people think that's a bad thing
you know you're a broken person I love
it I'm a broken person because Allah has
allowed my pieces to fall down and now
he's allowing me to put myself back
together how I want to you know not by
how Society wants to not about how you
know having trauma is not a bad thing
you know it sounds like a scary thing
but it's not because it allows you to
see things for what they are you go
through what you have to go through and
then you grow through it and you're able
to now piece yourself back together
that's just New Perspective look I'm not
saying like you know trauma Is Not a Bad
Thing someone's just like yeah you got
molested as a child that's not a bad
thing how dare you I'm not saying that
right but even if that did happen to you
you know subhanallah that was your test
that happened by Allah's permission as
well too now what are you gonna do with
that right are you going to Harbor that
in or are you not going to be an
advocate for all children and are you
going to be an advocate for all people
who've been through that and use that
motion and now do something about it to
fight for justice for everyone those are
hey those are the same people right a
person who wants to Harbor that feeling
and internalize it and just like live
with that every day versus the person
who uses that as fuel to propel them and
they realize that this is my Underdog
Story I'm gonna help the whole oh my God
because that's why Allah allowed it to
happen to me I was abused at home went
through abusive relationships because
Allah wanted me to go through that so I
could be more relatable to the people so
that when the ummah feels that pain I
know what that feels like the average
person might not you know last episode
we spoke about like drugs and these sort
of things you know you know a shoe which
is totally fine obviously it might tell
you that something's right but they
never had that experience alhamdulillah
like Allah saved them from them may
Allah protect us all from them but a
person has been through it they have a
little bit more like hands-on experience
with that right not saying one's better
but you understand what I'm saying a
person who's been through abuse trauma
uh some type of childhood trauma sexual
trauma something like that they have a
perspective that no other person can
have you understand so when a person
speaks to you about it you're not just
going to be like I'll just have sabbah
that's not just a cliche answer you're
going to be give right you're able to
elaborate a little bit more so Allah
allowed you go to go through that so
tying it back in you know I've realized
how empty I was and they just expose how
broken I've always been I've been a
Broken Man my whole life starting from
my childhood starting from how I love
and everything like that and when Allah
put me back into the Dunya I went back
to what was making me whole before Allah
gave it to me even more bro like the
parties got even louder bigger I became
even better I I got even crazier
situations I got even in cooler High
Jinks everything
but I'm that same person who's the who's
the life of the party yo excuse Harry I
mean they didn't call me it's gonna call
me as well you know but you know I'm
here you know popping bottles doing all
that sort of stuff but that same person
is at you know three o'clock in the
morning driving home crying on the
highway because I feel so empty and
alone I just wanted love and I wasn't
getting that and I was chasing love I
was trying to find love in all the wrong
ways because I was hurt I was so hurt
you know and
um I admire reverts bro because they you
know like they have so many unique
stories and you know they take that hurt
that whether that be spiritual hurt from
previous religions that they might have
been growing up on or whatever LED them
to Islam and they allowed them to seek
the truth and they realized that it's
not a person that they were missing they
weren't broken because of that trauma
childhood it was that connection with
Allah and that revert is searching for
that that person who came back to Islam
realizes that what they're truly missing
is the connection with line obviously
that's what happened with me as well
I think this is the the very important
part to highlight
because you do have a lot of Muslims
like you have Army you have fired and
they had their own Awakening they had
their own part where it's like they
realized like damn like something is
missing like it could have been as
simple as Rami like your experience you
said that you were watching this video
on it was shaytan right yeah I believe
some how it became shaytan and then this
just made you see what
just uh I just listened to it I'm like
you know spawn a lot like I didn't say
that at the time but I was like well you
know this is interesting this is cool
I'm like let me look into this and I
just started watching more and more and
I'm like this this religion I was born
on that I never practiced you know this
has something here kept going into it I
got to like David wood videos
refutations to Islam then uh rebuttals
from Islam towards those refutations and
handling all them in such a a beautiful
manner Masha Allah I was like well this
this is it isn't it so weird that this
thing known as Islam that we were just
put on from birth right and we just had
it within Arm's Reach yeah we we didn't
know the value of it until we knew the
value of it yeah bro and what was it for
you
um well one of my mom and dad are
watching this they hate when I you know
talk about bro may Allah bless you for
watching and always tuning in but at the
end of the day make sure you subscribe
my dad oh dude make sure
okay the first ones bro
um I think my parents are our biggest
fans bro but uh what I wanted to say was
I had a similar story to you we didn't
even let him finish this story but no
there's a little intermission right now
but I was deep into jahilia
doing XYZ whatever that entails are that
you all use your imagination but you
shouldn't because you should assume God
of your brother stuck for a lot bro such
a paradox yeah okay yeah
um yeah I advise you please do not
expose yourself
so it's like going into that and just
living a life that everyone else was
living
following what Society was telling me
believing their lives of this will get
you happiness this will get you
Enlightenment this will get you
fulfillment do this everyone's doing
this don't be uh don't be a party pooper
you know don't be don't be boring and
don't whatever
and in that time I let that get the best
of me and this is a very slippery slope
because shaytan doesn't come to you in
the
then you were talking about another
episode of red horns tail Pitchfork none
of that bro shaytan comes to you as a
disguise from your friend from your
closer loved ones from your boys from
your homies right and before you know it
you're caught in it too deep and when I
was caught in too deep
I let it get the best of me and I was at
a point where I was like things were not
looking good bro let's say that and I
didn't think I would come out of that
situation and I did the only thing that
my parents fully etched Into Me growing
up the only thing that they really
hammered into me which was Dua
is this you know they would always tell
me I was I was always an inquisitive kid
so I was like what is Dua mom and dad
what is the one they were like you take
your hands you don't need to but
something taught me they're like take
your hands you make a request you cry
out for help out of desperate need to
Allah the creator of the heavens and
earth and you request and you beg him
for whatever you need
and you might get it you might not but
you never stop making Dua nonetheless
so was I in a state to be making Dua
probably not was that in a state for
prayer probably not
was I praying at the time who knows but
what I do know is it's like a federal
thing you know I knew at that moment I
have to it's kind of like a person
that's drowning you know there's there's
a lot of people that you know when they
fall into the water they can't swim
right they don't think about like well I
drown one not drown what's the buoyancy
and all this all this nonsense they're
just like making all these it's like a
fitra but it's like a survival mechanism
you know like they they do these things
to just keep their head above water even
if they're drowning like they're still
struggling bro it's like you know you
see in the movies when someone you know
holds you underwater you just you're
doing it right and that's that's like
the closest analogy I could give it's
almost like I knew in that moment I just
need to make Dua and I made go to Allah
I was like Allah get me out of this
situation you know I know I messed up
I'm the one that got myself into the
situation but Allah
if you're out there and you're listening
please help me out of this situation and
I will never ever ever ever ever
you know be caught up in this nonsense
ever again and
I'm not gonna say I made a whole 180 and
sell them a dream or anything like that
although those miracles do happen to
people but for me it was the first
glimmer of hope or Serenity peace
calmness Tranquility that I've ever
gotten in my entire life let alone deep
in jahiliyah and I knew in that moment
two things number one
Allah doesn't owe us anything
why do you give me that
and number two
well so continue number one not so I
could take for granted but number two I
knew that even though how deep down the
rung you know Direction I was I knew
that Allah is real
and it's just a fifth thing I was never
like atheist maybe agnostic but I was
like I knew Allah's real and I know
there's gonna be a day of judgment and I
know that if I act like those atheists
now that Allah has given me this peace
and I go back into doing XYZ
I knew the next time I cried out to
Allah if he doesn't help me
then I can't say anything bro at that
point I can't be like yeah Allah I was
gonna do it and if Allah was to you know
tell me that
I helped you once
but then you did it again you insist you
went back on your word I would literally
just be caught dead like in my tracks I
couldn't even say anything at that point
and I didn't want to test the mercy of
Allah
because I knew what happened when I you
know just took things into my own hands
so in that moment I was like okay I have
to like turn my life around and
what's a man if he doesn't have his word
bro so I had to keep my word with Allah
my pastor or deal or truth or whatever
you want to call it even though this is
like apples it's too it's not an equal
playing field it's not a mutual
agreement or anything there's no
contract right
Allah didn't know me this Allah is is
the 100 responsible for me getting out
of the situation right I had nothing to
do with it it was a mercy of Allah and I
was like I don't want to play around
with that bro I don't call it love call
it fear call it whatever but it was me
realizing at that moment then and there
that I I cherish this too much bro
and I kind of did leave things called
turkey and I know you know we were
talking about the reality of rivers and
people leaving jahilia you know Muslims
finding Islam later it's not always a
cold turkey right but for me it kind of
was for me it was not cold turkey you
know you go years
by behaving a specific way it's tough to
just like give that up but I will tell
you one thing though
um
this time around when I would do
something Haram it felt bad that was the
difference like when I when I accepted
Islam and like realized that this is the
way I need to follow and this is what
Allah wants from me now those same
things that were sins that before I
never considered sins I just thought it
was a night out or it was just something
to smoke it's just something to drink
social thing yeah yeah like nothing I
never thought twice about it now it
started feeling wrong it started feeling
I started feeling bad about it and I
started feeling the actual effects of it
you know and
um I remember when I like had just
accepted Islam and started following it
one thing that I quit cold turkey
alhamdulillah never had a problem with
it alhamdulillah was drinking I never
liked it I thought it was stupid I just
like never liked the thing I just knew
it was something social that we had to
do you know and again so many peer
pressure societal stuff you know and
it's just bad and that's expensive guys
like oh my God like I could just go on
about it it's just a terrible terrible
thing it's disgusting like it's disguise
I don't even have it's nasty it's still
disgusting I don't I can't say that
enough okay anyways and how you feel
afterwards is just so sloppy a lot like
it's just you just like come on okay
here's the thing if you really want to
be put off from like drunk people right
be the designated driver or that sober
person right you will see people for
what it is and it is annoying you're
babysitting everyone and you're just
like yo this is so bad like and then you
start realizing this is how I was I was
doing this too like oh you know what you
you just realized like yo this is not
how I want to live this is not how I
want to be so there were certain things
for me that was totally easy to give up
uh when I turned back to Allah but there
were certain things to me that were
extremely difficult one thing for me
that was extremely difficult uh was
women women was so tough bro just
because like I just love women I don't
know you know it just it was just so
tough but going back to that point when
something wrong happened it felt wrong
and that's an experience I didn't have
before where I would be coming back and
I felt ashamed I never thought felt
shame before you know doing it it always
felt like a badge of honor I'm texting
people I'm you know bragging about it
you know we're talking about again
what's gone on the body that's what
you're talking about now
you're like I I just really I really
rocked myself just now like come on what
was that like what was that all about
you know and I never had that experience
before prior to that it was just like
can't wait to tell the boys about this
now it's just like I don't want anyone
to ever know about this like this is
just it was a natural thing oh no like
cover me up like cover me up and it's
interesting because when Adam
like they they were exposed the first
thing that they got exposed was their
clothes that they were not wearing any
clothes and they immediately started
covering themselves up because there was
this this hayat that they had you know
and I think that that's what I
experienced for the first time
not first time like ever but first time
that you know like I remember it now
maybe last time was like when I was a
kid but like now when as like a little
bit more of an adult so I realized like
ah this is bad this is not good and I
remember my friend was just like oh so
what are you doing and I was just like I
was lying I was like nothing I mean you
know I didn't want to even say anything
before it would be the opposite you know
and this was a big big struggle for me
so I know like out there a lot of you
are probably still stuck in a sin you
know it can happen but just know that
don't give up on yourself because Allah
hasn't given up on you and that's
something that you got to remember you
know Allah hasn't given up on you on you
and you shouldn't give up on yourself
instead turn that that worry into
worship a little bit more you know what
are you worried about you know Allah has
given you some pure resources
he's given you seven pieces of bones
that you can use to prostrate to him you
have your hands you have your head your
nose right you know your knees you have
your feet you can just turn to him in
full sincerity and he'll respond to you
right why are you so upset why are you
giving up on yourself you are not your
sin that's something people need to
understand you're not defined by your
sin your identity is not your sin why
did the prophet saws look how prophetic
this was right and it's going back to
what you said in the last episode about
about that triangle about uh what was it
that you said about how you think how
you feel yeah thoughts feelings and
actions thoughts feelings and actions
right so you do bad you feel bad you
think bad and it's a loop right okay you
did bad Haram something wrong now you
think bad you feel bad loop loop loop
what are the prophet Muhammad say he
says when you do a wrong action replace
it immediately with a good action change
your state change your state immediately
break that Loop break that feedback
immediately why Allah is the most
forgiving no one had to die for for your
sin
don't worry it's okay Allah's nature is
forgiving Allah by default is very
forgiving his Mercy is forgiving you
know so if if you're someone out there
don't give up on yourself you know
because your journey this is a story
this is a scar this is something along
the way and you're gonna look back at
this and you're gonna see your growth
because as a new Muslim there's going to
be a you have to be a little bit more
flexible with yourself and realize that
look there's a learning curve that that
I have to go through and the prophet
saws mentioned that every son about him
is a sinner bro
like authentic narration and and the
best of Sinners are those that repent
so it's in our fitro bro to mess up
it is that's a reality bro a lot of
people don't want to identify with that
book yeah I just think it's crazy that
the plan of Allah is just it's so
perfect and we only see it when we're
looking back you know we don't see it in
the moment we're looking back now and we
can see it like you know we we I didn't
say mine but you guys said like what
kind of you know brought you back to
Islam and like for Rami it was it was
simple like he just watched this video
but like think about all the other stuff
that had to happen in order to lead up
to that and think about if I had your
situation all the stuff that had to
happen for you to basically get into
that moment where you had to cry out to
Allah thinking about you like what
happened before you had to get some
moment where you had your heart broken
you know I was like I had a whole bunch
of stuff happening I can't say that okay
um because before Islam I was engaged
and
um
you know I saw this girl as like the one
that was gonna you know be married to
all this stuff you know spend my life
with Christian woman but it's like bro
that didn't work out Allah had you know
I plan one thing I love playing another
yeah right and in the moment I couldn't
see it and I'm not gonna say that that's
what led me to Islam but that was a
factor yes you know so it's like it's
crazy to see how all these things are
just bringing us back to Islam and um
I I guess like the reason I wanted to
bring that in is to tie it all together
was like does it matter if you're
yeah it doesn't matter if you're a born
Muslim like we're all going to the same
place we all have the same path yeah
it's the path and your past is your path
and if we start making a different
meaning of our past because a lot of
times shaitan will cost causes to
overthink our past you know and think
that maybe we're not even worthy of
guidance maybe we're not worthy of a you
you're gonna pray you know what you was
doing yesterday and this is for people
like look the way I look at myself is
I'm I'm a recovering sinner there's
certain people that can't be around
because they're going to trigger certain
things about me when you go to like AAA
meetings right for Alcoholics Anonymous
you they tell you you're not allowed to
be in the vicinity of alcohol you can't
right so if I know people like maybe
smoking weed around me it doesn't matter
how clean I've been for how long I'm
this close to relapsing any at any given
moment why I have the muscle memory of
how do you roll a blunt I have the
muscle memory of how do you break it I
have muscle memory and it's like getting
her back on a bike I wouldn't know
exactly how to do it if I went to a bar
I would know exactly how to order a
drink right you keep yourself away from
these situations because you're a
recovering sinner right so that's how I
view myself I'm a recovering Center I
need to stay away from things from
people who lead me back people who
remind me of those things and remember
that our past has brought us on this
path you know and if you're someone
who's trying to get better you know
because there's a lot of us and you know
reverts or someone who's just coming
back to Islam you might just have this
streak or you're doing great but then
shaytan comes it's it is what it is you
know and you're gonna mess up you might
commit a minor Anderson or it could be a
major sin right and now he's going to
prevent you from
from coming back to him and this reminds
me of something
you know when Musa Islam had come to the
court of Ferron and
there was those two magicians right they
were the chief magicians they knew the
magic they knew it right he faced the
top of the top right
and um when obviously musa's time
defeated it they knew that this was
something real
they accepted Islam okay cool and we
knew that they died as Martyrs what
honors right they were not only the
first to accept the son but they also
died that same evening as Mars
alhamdulillah if Allah can forgive right
magicians people who were doing kuffa
and just wrong and Shirk and this and
that you're someone who believes in
Allah you believe in his Oneness you
believe that there's nothing worthy of
worship except Allah you believe that
the prophet Muhammed is the last and
final messenger of Allah you believe in
all the messages of Allah what makes you
think that he won't forgive you now this
isn't an invitation to just continue to
sin this is an invitation to remember to
turn back to Allah don't allow your sin
to hold you back don't allow this
negative baggage you know this emotional
baggage that's what I found that there's
a lot of negative emotional baggage that
people carry around with them Islam sets
you free of them when Khalid came to the
prophet Muhammad what took him so long
to accept Islam was he had emotional
baggage he had this baggage from behind
him and when the prophet Muhammad had
his brother came and he asked about
where's Khalid and and he said you know
he said khalid's too intelligent to not
be a Muslim and and then it was moments
of that that Khalid bin Walid came to
Medina and when he came over there
people were just shocked and said right
this is the big deal
he comes and he says you know take me to
the messenger's house and then what was
stopping him from accepting Islam bro
was his baggage it was his baggage what
was stopping him from coming on the
right path what was doing it was his
baggage
and he came to the messenger of Allah he
said that you know I've killed the
Muslims you know I've killed Muslims
I've attacked you I've done horrible
things to you right
I can I can be me I can be forgiven and
the prophet Muhammad saw some said
don't you know Islam forgives everything
so why are you why are you holding it
against yourself right why why like if
Allah has forgiven you why haven't you
forgiven yourself what's stopping you
from forgiving yourself you know Allah
has forgiven you already forgive
yourself as well move on let go of that
baggage you know but shaytan wants us to
hold on to that baggage he wants us to
hold on to those prior identities that
we had because he knows he could pull
you back in and lure you back in let go
of it Allah forgives everything Islam
forgives everything so what's there to
worry about you've done something wrong
repent turn back to Allah Allah hold it
so how was the actual Journey coming
back to Islam was it a smooth sailing
type Journey was it in waves bro like
what epic journey is ever smooth if
anything about any movie that you love
you know like just we love it when the
main characters going through it right
right when you think he's making it boom
he falls again right something else
happens to them they're making they're
making it something else happens bro
life and Journeys and epics and these
Amazing Stories We Are the hero of Our
Own Story you know it's not supposed to
be easy that was the first mistake to
think gender and all these things are
easy it's not supposed to be easy the
the highway to hell is huge it's wide
you know in the authentic narration and
when you know the Allah told the angel
to go check on the Hellfire he when he's
seen it he said that the it's so wide
that I feel like everyone will go to it
it has all the Temptations and when he
was checked to see the gender is so
narrow that I feel like No One's Gonna
Get to it you know so it's it's never
smooth man it's never smooth I had to
unlearn habits that I had I had to
unlearn things that that I I was taught
by Society on what is right from what is
wrong I had to let go of my own ego I
had to submit to Allah that Allah says
this no matter what I think I might
think it's this but Allah says that I
cannot justify my actions I would rather
just say Hey listen I'm weak struggling
but no justifying of the actions you
know and it definitely was not a smooth
sailing journey and I'm sure anyone
watching home and listening home it's
not smooth for you easy it's not it's
not smooth for you and that's what makes
your story epic you know embrace it
embrace the fact that it's not smooth
right okay think about this as a movie
right that this is your main character
you know you're going through the worst
time of your life right now okay it's
bad things are bad okay cool okay
awesome right but now it's in the second
half of the movie and we know the second
half of the movie gets better okay
things were like this but now what
happens tell the other side of your
story you've been focusing so much on
this story and this narration now turn
it around tell me what happens after
that because once you start thinking
that your story is improving that's when
it does start improving and that's when
you start putting your best foot forward
and trusting in the plan of Allah and
Allah will not disappoint you you
there's no way someone's going to
convince me that Allah will disappoint
you you're disappointing yourself bro by
thinking that he will disappoint you
alone want to support you put your
password forward and I love that you say
that bro cause
it just bro puts everything in
perspective and
the thing that I add to it is people
really gotta you know take a step back
and ask themselves like are they the
main character in their lives like do
they see themselves as the main
character or are they a side character
have they not been making the time for
themselves have they been running away
from all these things have they been
because think about the main character
if it's truly a main character the main
character is going to be taking care of
himself he's going to be running towards
Allah he's gonna have Allah basically
like you know like they're gonna be the
guidance is gonna be on point
everything's going on point but if if
you're like a side character
so like MPC if y'all are catching my
drift here like how dare you you're not
gonna
think about the MPC an NPC just kind of
like walking all over the place they'll
walk into the wall and they'll do this
like they ain't really doing much and
you know what they don't allow
themselves to take control of their
lives you know Allah doesn't control
your life right but you have to tie your
camel going back to that same example
we've used right you know a lot of times
people want to be the victim and just
blame Allah for their problems or blame
their their upbringing or the abuse of
the trauma for their problems and all
that sort of stuff and look we could
have done that too the problem I haven't
saw some could have blamed the fact that
no one picked in for the wet nurse and
he was left all alone that's a very sad
story
blame the fact that I was an orphan and
no one ever loved me and I was an orphan
I was adopted by my uncles my cousins
and everyone would eat in front of me
and I'd be left with the scraps look at
how many things but what we'd love about
it it's that it's a Underdog Story and
he rises to the top
so wherever you are right now you could
rise to the top you know I mean take
control of your story take control of
that narrative and don't allow you know
someone else to tell your story just
regain control of The reigns of that
story so y'allah you're in control of
the story of now let's turn this thing
around and it's going to be tough it's
going to be tough to you know grip grip
it and get it back on on course and the
funny thing about you know the course is
that you you're making that right but
it's you have so much momentum from the
failures from before that you're making
the right but it's not turning right
it's still moving to the other way you
look like you're gonna crash but you
have to trust in Allah eventually that
momentum will turn you in the right
direction you're just having that lag
from before and you're in lag time from
the previous failure so you don't see
the goodness right now but it does take
time it does you know and you have to be
patient you have to be just know that
listen there's a season for all these
things if you're hearing this right now
that means Allah wants the guidance for
you but you know you have to you have to
be willing to take it you know so what
do y'all practically think is uh what
people should start applying in this
situation what situation like let's say
um someone's okay realizing damn like I
have I am the main character in my life
like damn I am doing the dog like I I
needed I need to tie my camera and I
need to trust him online I need to do
something I need to change like what's
the first step for them I'm gonna
combine two things that brother SQ has
said I was gonna say your name real
quick by accident yeah we would have to
flip that one out yeah that would be a
bleep
um yeah but uh what I was gonna say is
you made this point before the the
Alcohol Anonymous thing right when you
quit and you're you're in let's say
therapy rehab you have withdrawn all
this you don't put yourself back into
the lines then you don't surround
yourself back with these people that are
doing the same thing right
and we also talked in the car bro when
we were going to get your frozen
lemonade that you never take one thing
out here show them that bro you already
know he's had he's a left hand brother
no no no no don't worry if you drink
with the right hand don't even try to do
that
that's the thing my man's my man's
talking at the takritis Bro right away
bro like
um so you look at you look at the point
that we were making the car you were
saying that you don't replace one thing
in your life except that you you don't
remove one thing in your life except
you're replaced with something else so
I'm gonna tie both of those points
together that you mentioned and it
brings me to the point that y'all
probably seen the episode with uh
brother Gabriel a few weeks ago
inshallah about the the whole uh his
story you know coming into some the
whole ex Muslim thing and what he was
saying is a huge reason that reverts
when they come into Islam or you want to
kind of make yourself that main
character take your life in the control
of your hands you know put Allah first a
main reason they can't do that is they
don't have that Community aspect they
don't have the surroundings so you know
how you were saying that you know let's
say you're getting your life together
you're leaving this you're leaving this
is back there right but if you're
leaving there and you want to come this
way and you want to kind of get your
life together how are you gonna do that
when you're not fulfilling a new
foundation and a new environment you're
not cultivating change all you're doing
is you're like okay cool I'm gonna leave
that and I'm just gonna go hear solo
dolo you're not here like okay I need to
get new friends maybe I need to surround
myself with those that are like-minded
kind of like let's say someone's broke
all their life right they don't have
money they want to become a millionaire
anyone can inshallah by the will of
Allah and they're like you know what I'm
gonna leave these bombs but I'm just
gonna work on myself alone you know can
it be done of course Underdog stories
you know it happened solo but if you
surrounded yourself with millionaires
with people that are making it you get
men foreign
it's a different ball game bro and
that's what Gabriel was saying the most
important thing in his opinion Above All
Else once you find out you want to you
know take your life into this Direction
come back to Allah turn back to Allah it
surround yourself immediately bro
because human beings as much as we don't
want to admit we'd rather be following a
wrong path
but have environment surrounding us
Community then be following the right
path but to be the only one
bro
um I agree wholeheartedly with stuff I
said I think it's very important that we
have that Community aspect
um the only thing that really comes to
mind I've had these ayats of the Quran
really playing on my heads fan online I
think it beautiful
guys it's he's going through he's
thinking about his eyes she had to pull
on with my phone to make sure I had them
right
now yeah he's not texting no one don't
worry guys he's engaged he's engaged but
um it's found a lot so first thing I
want to say if if when people realize
that they're the main character of their
life they have to also realize that
they're mainly and by mainly I mean
solely accountable right so this is
tough yeah this is not something like oh
I'm the main character I'm I'm the man
it's like you're also the man that's
going to be punished if you don't
perform right and you need to keep that
in mind and well it's very powerful
versus
this is the Surah that Allah everyone
even the normal Muslims put their head
in prostration towards Allah except one
man who brought dirt to his forehead
instead
um wow after after
he says have you seen the one who turned
away
he gave a little bit and then he
refrained right he gave a little bit he
did a little bit he worked a little bit
and then he stopped
Allah says
does he have knowledge of the Unseen
who fulfilled all of his tasks he did he
he fulfilled all those obligations every
single one and we know the story of he
was commended to slaughter her son he
would did it like that even his son was
like do it
yeah the lemonade got you don't worry
right he did it just like that he
fulfilled all those obligations right
um
and then this apartment
and that in the scriptures also it says
that every soul is accountable whatever
they earn what they did so if you're the
main character you're also the person
who's going to be punished for what you
do and that you can't give a little bit
because it's easy in the in the
beginning guys you never know that you
guys know the Kruger effect you ever
heard of that no tell us the Don and
Kruger effect does there's a chart all
right put a picture bro editor yeah
so you start anything new right you're
here you're at the beginning you're
confident when you do the first bit you
learn the first bit it's through the
roof like 100
and then the more you do and the more
difficult you realize it is it goes down
down down and then you go into what they
call like the pit of despair you're
actually negative you're depressed with
it and you're like I don't know if I can
do this anymore and I know we've all
felt this for something oh absolutely
100 many things I think maybe even most
things we've taught you in life we felt
this yes and most things I don't think
we come out of it we end it there most
people do unfortunately but if you keep
going the more you learn the more
confident you get and eventually you get
back up maybe maybe 80 90 confidence but
you never go back to 100 because you
realize you know that you'll never know
everything and that's a good state to be
and you're confident but you're humble
as well right some people when they come
to Islam they're very especially like
the Arabs when they come back they're
very fired up mashallah they have this
fire they're doing good and then it's
like
man you know I miss being with a woman
I'm in all this stuff and it's kind of
lost like you know
have you seen the one turned away they
gave a little bit and then they were
friends and they turned back in the end
that's literally the cougar effect bro I
just wanna I just want to give some
quick praise bro mashallah bro
um
because we're on the topic about you
know hard work and not giving up bro
this is your first time meeting us right
let's be honest yeah and I'm assuming
you think he's a native Arabic speaker
yeah he's not he didn't grow up learning
Arabic you didn't speak Arabic did you
no he doesn't know how to read Arabic he
doesn't know how to uh speak Arabic he's
not a native Arabic speaker so when he's
doing these you know reciting the Quran
talking about Ayah translation all this
it's all hard work bro it's so much
harder for someone that doesn't speak
Arabic like I'm assuming you me on her
right and that's him to include wow
that's and you know going back to what
you said about that dip effect this is
the time where most people quit but the
ones who get up and realize that I need
to pull my resources together and
recognize that they're in that dip
period those are the ones who are able
to survive because if you don't realize
you're in the dip this is normal for you
to go through that little sucky period
it's normal right it's a completely
normal effect but that's when people
want to quit the most right so for
example let's suppose someone's trying
to start a podcast right there's a sucky
period for in a podcast right bro so
we're trying to start a YouTube channel
it's just a terrible period where at
first it's all exciting because you're
learning how to edit and maybe you got
your first few subscribers and then just
like no one's watching the videos but
that's the time where you know the the
this is one of my favorite sayings you
know the the the froth from the juice is
separated you know that that's what
separates you from everyone else that's
the time we need to go all in on your
resources and get out of that dip and
prepare to go in that dip process and
structure and just know that this thing
is going to happen and you know you said
it best brother and you quoted the Quran
in a beautiful man of mashallah that you
know everyone has to be accountable for
themselves take matters in your control
they realize look and think about it any
problems that we're in we put themselves
in us like yeah a lot a lot of to happen
but you did it whatever problem you're
going through is something that you
created from your own hands and Allah's
Mercy he will get you out of that
problem as well too if you turn back to
him sincerely inside so taking taking
control of your life means you're taking
full accountability of your situation
Style again going to the other side of
things about going through the trauma
issues because someone might be like I'm
supposed to take accountability of me
getting you know uh sexually abused no
no that's not what I'm saying you don't
that's obviously something from Allah a
huge test a huge challenge that you have
to go through but notice what is in your
control is how you respond to that
challenge again going back to have you
become an advocate uh the voice for the
people the megaphone the speaker for all
little uh girls and boys who've been
through that you know have you become
the megaphone for them are you their
voice now because that's your choice
that's your control that's
accountability you could do that but yes
you had no control of what happened to
you asshai wasn't your fault but right
now are you going to use that to propel
you to take this next level because we
all need to be accountable for what's in
our control
you know not everything is in our
control obviously is in the loss control
but the things that are in your control
take accountability of that and just
push yourself to the next level 100 and
I think
the going back to the discussion
accountability is perfect because I
actually need to correct myself right so
it's doubly perfect
um
I was gonna say when you mention that
all the Arab speakers right the all the
autob speakers probably picked up on
some mistakes I made and that last bit I
actually I made a mistake there so
actually means that no soul would be
burdened with the sin of another so
accountability right there and the next
one is
and that's the one that says and every
soul will get what they earned so just I
wanted to correct myself on that may
Allah forgive me for that little step
but how did I correct it
it's in one of my
my favorite uh recitations
uh it's by um
it is
cute bro talk to the people man it's
there's two things we we commonly get
from DMS bro is the whole thing about
doubts
and then the whole thing about family
because we have stories from Ibrahim
from the Quran about how he would talk
to his father the issan the other that
he would have however the difference in
ideology and belief stark contrast
we we have stories about
and this is so much stuff yeah when you
when you get on your path on you on Dean
you're kind of leaving your family
behind but not really when you're a
river it's it's a techy situation right
so do you want to go into that just
really quick about that and and this
goes back to the original topic that in
the beginning we spoke about an abuse of
households and stuff like that you know
you mentioned something that you were
told you know off camera while that you
know you're they've shown you how to
what was that you said they showed you
how to be a father or how not to be is
that something like that like an abusive
parent or something oh okay okay so this
the parents okay so basically I knew a
brother who was abused by his father
right and this this brother was not
abusive towards his kids and I always
found that interesting right so I would
always go to them bro how are you
literally like the polar opposite of
your father because I see most people
just the cycle of hatred the cycle of
abuse the cycle of trauma whatever and
he basically said there's two types of
people one of them says I abused my kids
because I got abused as a kid and the
other one says I don't abuse my kids
because I got abused as a kid you see
when you mentioned the story about
Ibrahim alaihi Salam that's the beauty
of it he grew up in an abusive household
look at his dad look he his Dad tried to
kill him
right that's an abusive father let's
just get this down pat guys that's an
abusive father his own dad has taken him
to get him burned in the fire think
about that for a second but look how he
turns out with his son his sons right
both of his sons an amazing dad right
and you know hey Allah rewards him with
such an obedient son like hey you know
uh that he will uh he had the revelation
of that he was going to slaughter his
son with no contest just wanted to do
that you know and a lot of times parents
even might be like listen should be
that's how it should be look at look at
how ibrahimov Islam did it and look how
his son just submitted and just obeyed
their father didn't say oof didn't say
nothing like that
but you're also forgetting this
father-son project that they did called
building the Kaaba together you know
parents have you spent time with your
children have you really because
Ibrahimovic has spent a lot of time with
his son a lot they got to know each
other a lot father-son building activity
they were building they were building
some Treehouse they're building the
Kaaba they got to know each other and
their relationship got so much better so
if you're wondering why your children
aren't you know doing whatever they have
to do and they're not being obedient to
ask yourself have you taken interest in
what they want right and a return
inshallah you will see the blessings and
all that sort of coming around but going
back to your point right
um Ibrahim went through an abusive
household he was in an abusive household
right think about this as a child he's
abused by his father look what he did
his father literally put him on the
stake but he didn't turn out that way
and that just shows that you know your
circumstances does not dictate your
future your circumstances did not
dictate how you're going to be it's
accountability you hold yourself
accountable and just know that I am
choosing to do this and I would rather
you know move out of love than hatred
and that's how I want to be I want to
move
um with love in mind and my first self
would be in love rather than hate hate
and you know negativity and bearing bad
feelings from my past
yeah I get that bro but what I was
referring to were the people in the DMS
that were talking about let's say I
accepted Islam though and my mom found
out and kicked me out
oh wow you know let's talk because I
accepted Islam and my dad found out and
he caught me off wow he blocked me wow
yeah it's been a year they haven't
spoken to me that's tough and we go
start uh Gabriel Romani on the podcast
and he was talking about the same thing
when he accepted Islam it took him Years
bro to just tell his parents
and he wasn't even like a dependent to
them you know it was tough wow so
imagine people living under their
parents roof I you know what not only is
it what a test but look how close to the
sahaba they actually are think about
that look how close to the actual side
of their lifestyle actually is if you
look back at the companions who dealt
with this exact issue we never had to
but look at their their their their
struggle look at their reward that
they're gonna get and look how close to
the dean of of how it started off
they actually are to the bare roots for
the foundations for the fundamentals
right it's almost a form of like Halal
jealousy like wow like that's something
you have to go through but this is the
interesting part Allah going back to the
Ayah he wouldn't like test a soul or a
person with more than what they can
handle right Allah knew that you could
handle that but
so he didn't get tested with that
brother SQ didn't get tested with that
you did because you're stronger than me
in that regard you understand you know
you had a different test to how to come
to Islam versus how I did versus how a
person who's getting kicked out by their
families that just shows that your level
of forbearance is at a different level
than the average person so if you have
to do something that's above average
your reward is going to be above average
too it's not going to be the same as
ours your reward is at a higher level
right your struggle is at a higher level
so why wouldn't your reward be at a
higher level too and Allah has chosen
you that should give us you you know
comfort you know when Musa and Islam
is
approach it approaches the cave and
Allah reveals himself and Allah he gives
them this mountainous task mountainous
right now you're gonna go defend on and
you're gonna tell him there's nothing
worthy worship like the whole thing
right now look look you know you could
this is the time where you just
self-doubt Allah really me like are you
sure that's not what happened right
instead he embraced the challenge right
that's something that's we've left that
we've stopped embracing the challenge
embrace it wow this is the challenge
you've given me Allah so what did Musa
Islam say instead of complaining about
his circumstance situations I don't know
they have a bounty on my head I don't
know
right he acknowledged that this can only
happen if you expand my chest and you
make my Affairs easy for me so Allah if
you have put me in a situation where I'm
in a household where my parents don't
want to accept me and they might kick me
out Allah like you put me in the
situation so give me the strength to
deal with it you give me the strength
and you expand my chest because this is
your responsibility you put me in this
so alone grant me that and out of
humility out of humility
expand my chest for me right and make my
Affairs easy for me he's talking to
Allah directly
make my Affairs so easy for me expand my
chest for me right and just talk to
Allah like Allah you put me in a
situation because you knew this was best
for me this is a mountain this task for
me Allah without your help I can't do it
so Allah I need your help the whole way
but never ever doubt that you can't do
it don't doubt that because that's how a
Musa
hmm
I'm short man mashallah have you ever
gotten doubtable on your journey
I think that's a very normal thing right
like I think it wasn't bro I have but I
mean or not it's such a normal thing but
how does that work bro because Gabriel
was talking about it as it's rarely like
a logical thing so he was saying that
there were things that he intellectually
would like address you know because I'm
sure you see all these clowns on YouTube
all these people you know talking you
know taking things out of context and
they've all been refuted time and time
and again but Gabriel was saying that
even though he rationally refuted these
doubts there was still like a seed that
was planted inside and he just couldn't
get it and bro I myself I don't want to
talk too deep into doubts but I would
always have this one doubt bro it's it's
kind of weird though it's like an
intrusive thought but it was like What
if like you know Islam is just like the
highest level of like
so have you heard of Elon Musk
simulation Theory
so basically I think Robbie knows about
it right so Elon Musk basically said
that in the simulation theory that uh a
proposed I guess atheistic model is that
the world was created by chance
obviously but we were created by like we
were programmed in a way but like like a
video game by these beings or these more
intelligent right but Rami will talk
about how like you know if that happened
then who created them you know like it
would lead to infinite regression right
and we had to be created by an uncaused
cause and that kind of gave me peace
right but I was like
it's still it's still I still got caught
in that Loop though like what if it's
just like a like a simulation like we
were just created like we made video
games Super Mario Bros and all this
nonsense right and these these things
these two dimensional pixels in the game
were created by us what if that was the
same thing but like a more super
intelligent form of Consciousness or
life and they created us and this kind
of tripped me out for a long time and it
for a long time I could I could have
intellectually refute it
and and find peace and comfort in Allah
in Islam but it never really went away
until one day it did but for me it was
doing active voluntary acts of worship
coming closer to Allah that got it away
but when I talked to other people in
reverts for them they did other things
for some of them these things never went
away so do you have anything like that
you know there's a narration of the
Prophet Muhammad about when it comes to
doubts of the shaitaan and perhaps
valorami you might know about this
better about when the shaitaan comes to
you with a specific type of doubt and I
read this somewhere and maybe someone in
the comment section could help us out
with this as well too
um about how the shaytan
um has left certain aspects of things
and he comes to you with these doubts
and one there was a statement that the
prophet Muhammad taught us to say uh
which sort of just dissolves the entire
situations right and the main concept is
that you believe in Allah and his
messenger forget about all these
intellectual stuff and all that at the
end of the day when you boil it all down
if you believe that there's only one
Creator and and moham is the final
messenger of that's all you need you're
Muslim you're that's all what you need
right that level of thinking you're not
ready for that yet you're not ready for
that type of thought you're not ready
for those type of movements focus on
what you do know and all any type of
doubts that you have leave them aside
right now Focus what you what you
actually do believe in you believe in
Allah in this messenger then that's
sufficient for you that's enough for you
you don't need to go down these path and
all that stuff and bro look at the
person that you have to quote right now
Elon Musk Elon Musk he himself is lost
he named his child a freaking a keyboard
he just said there that's my child's
name you know what I mean like look who
you have to quote and remember a
creation himself who's trying to give
you an idea when we should be hey what
did the prophet Muhammad saw some say
about us what do you say about that and
look at our knowledge look at how much
it lacks that you know I don't even know
what I would have to do in the situation
I mean Allah protected from doubts but
we need to focus on what we know that is
certain anything that's doubt you leave
it right anything it's not full you
leave it that theory you don't
understand leave that that alone because
that's not helping you in the situation
it doesn't it doesn't do anything for
you like what value is that really
providing for you are you telling me
that we're in some stimulation some game
you really believe that there was this
alien like creatures like come on this
is not a science fiction movie like if
you really think about like come on cut
it out right but you leave what it is
for the sake of Allah and you just focus
on what you do know that you know that's
Allah and it's messenger and that's it
I'm gonna look this up too I'm
definitely I have to look it up now
no no okay now you have this what's up
let's see
we got 59 minutes bro inshallah a few
more minutes and then wrap up so you got
you got a brother and sister let's say
that's born into Islam or the river you
know they come into Islam they're trying
to come back to the right path and a lot
of them are
mentally convinced that Islam is the
truth okay but they don't want to do the
hard work
they I hear this in a lot of people I
don't want to air the the brother's name
that you know tells me this
um a lot
or the sister's uh name that tells me
this a lot because this is such an
important thing but they're like I have
so much faith in Islam that I know it's
the truth
but why do I need to pray it's in my
heart
why do I need to pray because I already
believe in it that's a very good point
that's a good point and I want to
mention this right now right here right
um anyone interested in knowing this you
know I've been shooting this with swaxic
the whole time just going about it
brushing and all that sort of stuff
right if I were to if I were to help
mashallah uh if if I were to just tell
you right without brushing my teeth
without Miss walk without nothing that
might I've eaten everything all day
mashallah you know mashallah made
amazing food you know we ate all these
sweets we had all these things and I
told you my teeth are clean
you'd look at me and be like that's not
true
I said yeah I know it's clean you'd be
like did you brush your teeth no did you
do some sock no how can you say your
teeth are clean it's because I feel it
my teeth are clean they're clean and
you'll be like no there's an actual
process of cleanliness that you have to
perform on your teeth to make that claim
if you say that my heart is good my
heart is clean the question is how did
you brush your heart because Salah is
the purifier of your heart Salah
purifies your heart it's the cleanser of
your heart because guess what happens if
you don't cleanse your heart the same
way if you don't cleanse your teeth it's
not the sweets I'm giving you guys a
dental lesson right now it's not the
sweets that cause the cavities it's the
acidity from the sugar that causes the
cavity and this untreated nature when
you don't treat the acid you leave the
acid it rots the plaque of your teeth
the enamel of your teeth and you develop
a cavity right it's the acid so you're
sinking hair oh my heart is clean well
Habibi what did you do to clean your
heart what did you do right oh source
trust me no but this is the question
right how did you clean your heart
saying your heart is clean okay tell me
that process
did you clean your heart if they could
did you clean your heart Quran did you
clean your heart uh the five daily
prayers did you clean your heart if you
didn't say that that means your card is
already catching a cavity and you don't
even know it you don't even know it you
think that it's not and guess what our
version of cavity is what the prophet
Muhammad saw some said that there's this
tiny black dot that just gets put on
your heart a tiny one a very tiny tiny
tiny black dot that gets put on your
heart every sin you commit until your
heart is fully covered with black dots
there's no turning back bro and that's
the time the only thing that could clean
it and that's why the process is called
teskeya the cleansing of the heart you
have to cleanse the heart no one can sit
here and tell me that their heart is
clean and they don't need to pray
because my heart is good to have a good
heart who said your heart is good what
treatments have you given to your heart
to say it's good you understand if we
keep dyeing our hair I mean I don't got
any but if we keep dying your hair you
know I mean we keep dyeing her hair
we keep bleaching it bleaching and
bleaching and bleaching and women who do
that they bleach the hair again and
again and again your hair eventually
dies So eventually the salon person the
hairdresser will be like this and you
need to stop that process you know you
need to start putting the conditioner on
and all that sort of stuff right but no
no my heart my hair is going to be fine
you can't say that okay what would you
say to the heart the same thing if
you're saying that my heart is clean the
question is how have you been cleaning
it where is the toothbrush for the heart
where is your brush for the heart
because the brush for the heart
according to Islam is that salad that
you're saying that you're already done
so the same way that you need a
toothbrush to clean your teeth a miswax
to clean your teeth you need something
to cleanse your heart and for us the
cleanliness the cleansing of the heart
the purification of the heart is the
Salah is the salukkah is these things
that is following and a beating and
obeying Allah because when you're not
obeying Allah by not praying you're
getting the dots on your heart so you're
tricking yourself to believe that you
you know you're hard to clean this now
until one day you're cheating you're
falling off you're getting infections so
on and so forth and the sections of the
heart are coming what form sadness
depression anxiety loneliness lack of
content which society's normalizing by
the way oh everyone has it yeah yeah
yeah and and yes these thoughts do come
about but when you have the escar when
you have the purification when you have
the Dua process you're able to heal the
heart so the question to her or to
anyone thinking this is how have you
been cleansing your heart how have you
been and we're not negating the fact
that it's supposed to be hard we agree
it is a lot oh yeah change you know yes
but at the end of it that's the thing
like you were talking about you know
cavities diabetes blood pressure bro
what did they see this stuff runs in our
family left right and center but here's
the thing you could be off course with
the nutrition with your program with
your Fitness everything first couple
decades of your life you're not going to
be out of shape you're not going to be
this is you're not gonna be on
prescription medications it catches up
to you sooner or later it's kind of like
the silent killer right and that's the
thing yes praying fox has a lot of
pressure is known as a sound killer 100
yeah so so yes you are required to pray
fast times a day you might not do it
overnight you are required to you know
let's say uh men and women have their
Aura you know good job for men and women
yes we got a faster Ramadan it's tough
bro listen
being a born Muslim that was born into
Islam and fasting since a young age bro
I still feel some type of weight during
Ramadan it's tough I still do it though
but it's tough and you as a river I'm
sure you can relate to it that it's so
tough you know the whole meme's about
not even water and all this yes bro not
even water it's tough and we're not
saying it's supposed to be easy and
we're not saying oh you know just
toughen up and stop stop being a wimp
about it just do it we understand it's
tough bro we're going through the same
thing but if you've signed up for Islam
just know that this is a part of it
you're not going to change you're not
going to do things you're not going to
change the religion are you saying that
but why do I have to pray and all that
sure stuff that's changing the religion
you know and you have to realize that
this is your enough speaking this is not
you this is your enough speaking what
enough for a lot of lemon enough's is
that carnal desire there's you see see
my bro this is what we need to realize
that the shaytan we have two enemies
obviously one is shaytan and ones are
nafsa the nafs that
only get satisfied when it displeases
Allah think about this this is enoughs
that only gets Happy When It displeases
Allah it only feels complete and
satisfied when it displaces of uh Allah
right uh and Allah
right I believe so uh what if someone
correct me please I could be wrong I'm
not the one I should be quoting over
here that's around me okay let's leave
it at that okay there's someone correct
me right but the nafsa LA Mara is
enoughs that
um that that calls you to disobey Allah
so you're following your nuts you're
following that desire that only gets
happy to disobey a lot like it gets
happy to be lazy at the time of prayer
it gets happy it's satisfied it's
satisfied when you don't pray to Allah
it's satisfied when you don't remember
Allah that's what makes it happy right
it's this self-sabotaging mechanism
that's within us the shaytan uses to
operate to poke holes in us that allow
allows him to just use us like a little
puppet that's why when he's even locked
for the the major gen
um are locked up in the Manta Ramadan
Ramadan why are we still committing
sense because not only are we on
autopilot but we have the Naf salamara
you know we have the enoughs that causes
us to disobey Allah and that's what
we're following we're listening and he's
put so much you know in our hearts and
in our ears and all that sort of stuff
that you know this negative self-talk in
this voice is causing us to be lazy so
when you find yourself lazy just know
that this is a part of the shaytan this
is a part of his plan to make you
disobey Allah right and that thing that
you find yourself lazy for Allah gave
you that like that thing that you're
ignoring to the thing that you're using
to ignore Allah Allah has given you that
thing that you're doing ignoring Allah
with you know I mean so like we just
really need to this is the main thing
bro
making Allah a priority and not an
option because that thing that you're
doing is your priority and Allah has
become an option let's just keep in 100
with each other right like you've made
Allah an option and you have to make
Allah a priority and you might say that
but why do I have to pray and all that
because the truth is you've prioritized
your life your Dunya and you have made
Allah an option and that's just what it
is and the only way we could make Allah
into a priority is when we acknowledge
the current state that we're in and
that's what it would have to be see
people can agree on this day of social
media there's so many apps right for
example I got asked you on Instagram bro
I got SQ on you know all these apps
where do I message you most I messaged
yes why
direct contact I have some people though
I'll hit them up on Snapchat nothing
else yeah I have some people hit them up
on Instagram nowhere else I know
Arnold's falling asleep over here bless
you
um I know that for every single person I
have in my circle there's a preferred
method of communication not just a
preferred method but a direct
communication where I know they'll see
that message they're on this app more
here we go
here's the thing Romy always mentions
this that we know that the most beloved
acts the Allah loves the most beloved
the things that he has made obligatory
right meaning the most obligatory things
that we have to do in Islam such as
Salah you know zakat Ramadan fasting all
that stuff
um all of those things Allah loves the
most then the slave does voluntary
things until he gets close to Tola but
hear me out so you're here noticing this
person likes to be messaged on Instagram
more this person will only reply if I
email them this person reports only if I
text them this person I can only call
they don't text
but here I know Allah wants me to praise
Allah because he has made his obligatory
meaning he loves it the most but I'm
gonna choose to just tell myself I love
Allah and just not do anything about it
or I'm gonna do other things
bro it doesn't work like that at the end
of the day if he truly loves Allah you
would be praying that's just because if
you if you love Allah if you love any
like let's suppose like bringing this to
obviously an example to a person like
when you love someone especially in the
beginning of relationships you really do
anything for them right you do things to
please them so on and so forth love
Allah
you want to get to know him more you
want to get closer to him and all those
things right and just remember out there
you know don't don't try to change the
religion around but mainly just remember
that Allah loves the Deeds that are
consistent so start with that one prayer
start with that one prayer and just take
it from there see and just build on top
of that prayer right and just build that
sort of momentum that positive momentum
right build your stamina that spiritual
stamina build that up a little bit by
getting more consistent with your Deeds
right don't think that you have to hit
all five immediately is all five or
nothing right we spoke about this you
know start with that one start with that
one that's the most easiest to you right
perfect that add another one add another
one or perfect that and Allah just watch
how Allah makes it easy for you because
he knows you're striving in this
direction but don't ever think that you
have to you could just abandon them all
and Allah and all that the the first
thing that the son of Adam will be
questioned about is the prayer so don't
don't play around with that you know
start with that consistent action and
guess what you start with the knee of
the look I'm gonna start with one
Insha'Allah and I'm Gonna Keep building
it keep building it keep building it and
then two three and I'm Gonna Keep
building my stamina until I get to five
and then guess what
you die in that process Allah knew the
Nia and where you're directing towards
you get me he knows where you're headed
towards so you don't want to die in a
condition where oh I don't have to pray
versus I'm trying you're trying you're
trying you know and we always want to
die in a condition that we're trying and
going back to what you said take control
of your life don't be a victim over here
don't be in all that you know what I
mean and everyone will be responsible
for what they have done
I'm in so
as much as I would love to you know tie
this up uh would you say that that's how
someone develops that love for Allah or
would you say there's something else
because you said that was an important
part it's like if if you love Allah then
you're not going to be missing the
prayer you know you're actually going to
make an effort so how would someone
actually have that love for Allah you
know to me it seems very simple but for
another person
you know if I say oh I love angel so
much I gave us another example last
episode four months ago but
you know if I say I love animal
he's my best buddy I love him you're
like oh really when's his birthday I'm
like I don't know okay well what kind of
hobbies do you have them like how am I
supposed to know that you know it's like
well you have a nickname for him I'm
like I don't even know how to spell his
actual name bro it's like it's like how
do you love this what's this lip service
that you love him and he's your bestie
or is it you really exactly you're
actually rather than yeah and there are
actually that's a good example because
there are people like oh I love that
person oh yeah he's great I love him
they actually don't know him so it is
fake 100 so you want to love Allah he
got to know him yeah we get to know him
to get Allah love you back you have to
please him you have to do work for him
yeah so how would this person get to
know Allah well Allah it makes it easy
he describes himself in the Quran you
read the words of Allah in the Quran
right you got to know his 99 Names his
attributes what he's done for you and
other people right like the Hadith the
man who killed 99 people and so on and
so forth they get to learn about these
characteristics of Allah and what they
mean and it's very in-depth analog give
a small example
these are two of the most commonly used
names for Allah you know Bismillah
alhamdulillah
right beautiful
what does actually mean if you look at
rahma people say the rule of Rahman
Rahim is
the womb of a mother
and Allah decided to use that term right
the woman mother to describe himself you
know like and if you look at the the
woman mother it provides everything that
the the the baby needs everything
protection nourishment a place to grow
so on and so forth
right and Allah uses that to be a Rahman
or to refer himself as
specifically is the one who's generally
merciful to everyone just because he's
you know the question of Allah existing
on this Earth that's what Rahman is I
wake up in the morning and all Muslim
wakes up in the morning I get food they
get food I drink water they drink water
he's right
is a specific type of of merciful Rahim
is you see translated as especially
merciful it's the people who go out of
their way to please Allah they go out of
the way to get that special extra Mercy
from Allah and that Mercy on the day of
judgment as well so when you break it
down like that's like I know so much
more about Allah now just by
understanding what is
and and you're hitting it on the head
bro it's a disease in the heart it's
there's a disease in the heart that
stops us and we have to purify our heart
the number one thing that we need to do
and how at least I would like to think
about it is make the Nia make the
intention ask Allah Allah fill my heart
with your love make me learning about
your attributes easy for me Allah
fulfill my heart with your love and
pleasure Allah allow me to understand
who you are and help me Allah discover
you help me learn more about you Allah
make this path easy for me Allah be
pleased with me you're purifying your
heart right now and you're actually
calling out to Allah and just watch I I
genuinely believe that when your heart
is seeking true guidance Allah obviously
will not
and there's this one thing that I want
to end on you mentioned this one Dua
that Allah will never reject
which is what
do I have guidance go into the law of
guidance you know we know that our duas
some may get accepted they all get
accepted like Allah hears all of them he
accepts them right but they might not
manifest like some manifest in this
Dunya right some will manifest in the
Hereafter because Allah was saving you
and some will you know protect you from
a Calamity that was happening what do
you mean by that so basically a Calamity
was coming your way and your daughter
was going up and the though I met the
Calamity and plus it was like a neutral
effect
but there's one Dua that Allah
never ever Rejects and it's a Dua that
will always come true for you and that
is the Dua of guidance that is a Dua
that will always get accepted so don't
ever think that that's not when you ask
Allah for guidance of your heart when
you ask Allah for guidance for your
spouse when you ask guidance of your
children when you ask guidance for your
uh the happiness of your home and
anything related to guidance and just
goodness in that direction Allah will
always always accept that Dua which
they're all good but you will see the
manifestation of that guidance and it
will always come true
when you said the whole purification of
the heartland
remind me of the series that abutemiah
made have you guys seen that on YouTube
purification test kit right yeah shout
out shout out yeah if you're watching
this we will hardly invite you inshallah
but um no no
what he said in the the series is
a lot of benefit a lot of benefit it all
links to everything I was saying here
but I think this is a great note to end
it off on I think we hit a lot of
beautiful points I'm very hungry
with that being said
foreign
[Music]
foreign